une autre sorte de performance matin
celle des couturiers français qui trouve
le moyen de sortir tous ensemble leurs
collections dans la même semaine c'est
la tradition mais c'est quand même pas
bien pratique
cela dit voici debout défilé de jolies
mannequins un poil d'extravagant si au
bout du compte est bien plein les
mirettes pour des spectateurs triés sur
le volet la mode 86 côté dames vu par
france roche la semaine de la mode a
commencé sur les trottoirs de l'avenue
montaigne hommage sur asphalte pour des
couturiers d'hier madeleine vionnet paul
poiret ou pas qu'un des flacons est
passé aux projecteurs pleins feux sur
l'été 86 qui sera d'abord militaire pour
cardin guerrière casque et me walkyrie
me chauffe souris pour balmain uniforme
immaculé d'officiers de vaisseau spatial
pour jeunes filles de troupes se grille
de guy laroche et gris encore père les
souris pour philippe venet j'ai
l'impression qu'elle a des contredanses
fort tard turban rose rose comme
l'imperméable de paco rabanne qui aiment
les dragées chanel aussi le bleu de ce
tailleur s'appelle layette coquette
madame grès mlle paille qui a fait cette
robe plein d'aveux troublant mais c'est
le bleu marine qui domine chanel
par-dessus camélia en hommage à la
fameuse dame et nina ricci des lunettes
pour voir la vie en bleu bleue à pois
blancs ferro blanc à pois bleus hanae
mori blanc / nuit bleue jean denis
cherer bleus uniforme dorante
républicain père scouts qui propose à
son pilote avec pantalons et des
lampions au poignet révolutionnaire
encore ce décolleté de philippe brunel
est toujours un drapeau rouge pour
ferrero un bras peau qui se transforme
en papillon papillon qui nous emmène
vers les parterres les poulets volant
les jupes aux coquins comme le fuchsia
de guy laroche qui hésite entre garden
party et fran ce coq fleurs et tuteurs
pour le koan aimant
macif prodigue sur les jardinières de
serge lepage et elles ont peur du soleil
les petites fleurs modèle de jean patou
comme sale évanescente et en mousseline
et de carven balma nous propose une
belle rose dans son vase
merrill en va de rose en balade à la
recherche de leurs signes du zodiaque
sur les aciers de mick micheyl est de
plus en plus rose l'orchidée exotiques
de pierre cardin maintenant place aux
sherazade voleuse d'arc en ciel aux
peaux d'âne avec leurs robes couleur du
temps soleil et mer pour nina ricci
crépuscule pour givenchy nuit et jour
pour 30
soupir de l'aurore pour rejoindre
richard eyre océans ou forêts endormi
pour paco rabanne enfin pour alain maury
des couchers de soleil passionnant